hey everyone
welcome to apogee up close my name is
erfan bakke i'm a customer engineer with
google cloud
helping our customers make better
architectural decisions as well as
better api management decisions
and today we'll be talking about
insights driven api
programs and the objective
is just to share our philosophy on
analytics and monitoring
and related to your business right i'll
i'll give you a lot of examples of how
our customers are leveraging insights
to make their businesses better to make
the api programs better
and then toward the end i'll take you
through a demo
that will showcase everything that we
talk about in the presentation
but the central idea really is that a
business needs real-time insights on
multiple different levels
to be agile and i'll show you today on
how you can get
those insights i'm sure you're familiar
with apogee it sits
in the middle of all of your services in
your applications and all of the data
that goes through
between your applications and your
services it goes to apogee
and the good thing about this is that
apogee has
a lot of data passing through and it can
tell you can give you the right insights
on
how your services are doing both on a
business level
as well as on an operational level and
when we are talking about this data
right
one thing to keep in mind is that the
data is usually associated with a
particular entity
so on the left you have the customer on
the right you have your backend systems
and that's how the data flows left to
right and right to left
and it is associated with a customer and
application
and a developer and it accesses
particular apis
which are part of different products of
yours
and in turn it those apis in apogee then
they
interact with specific backend systems
right
so all of these insights are very
specific to the particular entity
thus they can give you a good glean
on how your business and your api
program is doing so now let me tell you
about
our philosophy behind insights we look
at insights in a lot of different levels
and the first level is just record
business right everything
starts at your core business kpis
what is your business strategy and what
are the metrics that you need to track
to achieve it
and you would want to track that and you
can do it in apigee
in a very close to real-time basis be it
your revenue
or your subscriptions or the health of
your marketing campaigns
you can track all of those insights in
apogee
the second one is the insights about
your api program
right how is your api program doing how
many developers are signing up in a
particular week
the different applications the
developers are making how are they
consuming your apis what are
the experiences that the end users are
getting so all of those insights you can
get
from a good api management platform like
apigee the next one is at a product
level
right so within your api program you
would be exposing a lot of different
apis bundled together
as a product that represent a cohesive
functionality
and you want to see how those products
are being consumed by your customers
and you want to see how one product
relates to the other
and figure out how you can make them
better and invest the right resources
to make them better and lastly the
operational level analytics
for your operations teams and these have
to be real time so if there is something
wrong
in your apis on apogee or even in your
backend systems you want to get alerted
in real time with the right amount
of information that will help you solve
that particular error and you'd be able
to get that
with apogee so now let me talk about
some of our customers that
are using apigee analytics on all of
these different levels
so one of the customers i want to talk
about is t-mobile t-mobile is
one of the largest telecommunications
providers in the united states
and they are reinventing themselves as a
technology company
they are modernizing the entire stack
and they're using apogee
as the api layer on top of everything to
manage
the apis and govern them and all of that
so
one of their key business metrics that
they track are subscriptions
right and they're able to get business
insights
into how the api program is supporting
that key business strategy and how many
subscriptions they're driving
so thinking about t-mobile it has a good
online presence
it also has a very good brick and mortar
concrete offline presence
right it has thousands of stores across
the us
but at the same time they're also
selling through big big box retailers
and they would want to find
out what kinds of demographics
resonate better in one channel versus
the other
right the people who would buy t-mobile
subscriptions
in the retailer target may be of a
different demographic
than folks that buy the subscriptions at
best buy or walmart
right and you want to make sure that you
are appealing to them you're providing
the right kind of product to each one of
them
and that's possible by gaining the right
insights from that demographic
the other customer i want to talk about
is domino's pizza
now you would think that domino's is in
the pizza delivery business
but actually they are in a b2b business
servicing their franchise owners
and these franchisees they have their
own i.t systems
then domino's needs a way to integrate
into their delivery systems and their
payment systems and all of that and
they're able to do that
with apogee but at the same time to stay
competitive
and lure the the franchise owners
in staying with dominoes and opening up
even more franchises
they need to provide them with relevant
insights
on how they can make their programs
better
and with a platform like apogee as all
of the data is flowing through
they would be able to give them insights
on
how what a what does the best delivery
experience look like
right who are the target demographics
what are they interested in
across different geographies and what
are the success factors and success
criterias
that the franchise owners can implement
to make their businesses better
the other customer i want to talk to you
about is walgreens
and walgreens is really a classic
example of
a customer that has developed a robust
developer ecosystem
walgreens if you're aware it is one of
the largest pharmacy chains
in the united states back in 2008
they started to experience a drop in
their photo business because
folks weren't using film roles anymore
and they were
using their smartphones instead to take
pictures
and then it was really important for
them to understand
the end user behaviors and figure out
how to
get those users back well they found out
that
they were taking pictures with their
smartphones but they
still wanted to get those pictures
printed
so they created some native applications
mobile as well as desktop
to get to to basically enable them to
get
those photos printed at the nearby
walgreens and that restored
some of their business but they said hey
i think
there is some more potential here and it
started
to get insights into what kinds of
pictures
were these customers printing and they
found out that a lot of this traffic
was coming from other photo services
that would enhance
the customer's photos for example at
halloween time
you would upload a picture to one of
these services
and decorate it with pumpkins or
something right
so they were experiencing a lot of
traffic from such services
they said all right how about i expose
my api
my photo prints api to these different
applications and services
and incentivize them to route the
traffic
to get the photos printed at a nearby
walgreens store
so they did that and their ecosystem
exploded
right there were actually net new apps
that the developers were making
just to tap into the incentives that
walgreens would give them
to to direct traffic to their stores
so that was very successful and then
they replicated that model
to other products as well so now they
have
a plethora of products ranging from
prescription
refills and rewards programs and home
delivery services
that are basically just apis that
they're exposing
and they're being integrated into
developers applications
and thereby um giving
more business and traffic to walgreens
and they were able to do so
by really understanding their end
customers and their shopping patterns
as well as understanding developers what
they need and
incentivizing them to
to to partner with them and send them
the right traffic
the next thing i want to talk about is
operational insights and monitoring
and this is actually used by a lot of
our customers and a lot of different
verticals so i won't give you a
particular customer's example
but let me let me tell you about the
motivation actually of
why we um why we created
the monitoring module in apogee
some of the largest retailers in the us
and across the globe actually
are apigee's customers and at critical
times of the year like the new year sale
or
the black friday or cyber monday sale
they experience enormous amount of
traffic
right so for example in 2018 black
friday
we experienced close to 110 000
transactions per second sustained over
long durations of time
and it's important that these services
for these customers they're up and
running without any disruption
because every second of disruption could
cost them
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
dollars in revenue
right so apogee has a really robust
api availability rate we surpass our
slas
but our customers said that hey
sometimes there are
things on our end um that we need to
troubleshoot
some some of our services get down um
for a variety of different reasons
and we would love to get some alerts
for us to be able to fix those issues
fast and get get up and running really
fast
so that was the motivation behind apogee
monitoring
it addresses a particular need
for the operations teams right there's a
lot of pressure these days for them to
resolve issues very fast quickly
diagnose issues
and the data that apogee has which is
uh specific to the entities accessing
the apis
as well as services that the api is tied
to
in the different policies in your in
your proxies
and where exactly that error might be
occurring
is very useful in diagnosing these api
issues
so this is a diagram of how apogee
monitoring differs from just generic
synthetic monitoring
the the thing i want you to focus on
is that the alerts that you get they are
precise they tell you exactly
where the error has occurred they're
contextual
if the error is due to a race condition
right
if it's intermittent it'll help you zero
in on what exactly is wrong
and what is triggering that particular
error so just to sum it up apogee
analytics
actually covers all of the personas
that need insights into the api program
to make it better right it is your
business owner
to get insights on the strategy free api
program
and how it's doing with relation to the
different kpis that the business team
has set
so the api team to monitor the health of
the api program
and figure out what is gaining traction
what needs more resources
to the app developer to gain insights
into particular api
proxies in applications and
to ops teams to get real-time monitoring
alerts
and help in diagnosing the issues let me
jump right into a demo so this is how
the apigee platform looks
right you have a place to design your
apis you have a place to create build
your apis
productize them publish them and all of
that and then you have a place for
analytics
and to the left of the screen as you can
see these
are the out of the box dashboards that
you have
to target specific personas within your
organization
i would like to begin with
developers because once you have an api
program usually the first thing you
think about
is how are my developers consuming my
apis what is my engagement rate and all
of that
so this dashboard will give us just that
so right now as you can see
there is a funnel on the screen and
you'll be able to see how many
developers have signed up for the api
program
in our of the developers that have
signed up how many
have actually created applications how
many of those applications are active
and how many of those applications are
highly active
right and down below you'll be able to
see how is each of the application
performing what is the traffic that they
are
running to the platform what is the
error rate and all of that and then you
can dig in further
to analyze the high level metrics the
next thing
that you would be interested in just at
a high level
is a traffic composition right just tell
me what are
the top 10 proxies that
are receiving the most traffic tell me
what are
the top applications that are consuming
my services what are top 10 products
that are being accessed being consumed
and who are the developers that are the
most active
on my platform right so that is more a
high level
overview of the health of your api
program
if you're looking at the end users if
you're a product manager you would want
to gauge where are my end users located
right you'll be able to do that with
the geo map attribute with uh with
apigee over here as you can see
i have a lot of users coming from united
states but i also have presence
global presence in australia and norway
and china pakistan
a lot of places so if i click on the us
i'll be able to see the different states
where traffic's coming from
most of it looks like it's coming from
california i can dig in deeper
and see what are different counties that
are sending me
this traffic you can also see what are
the devices
that are um accessing your
your applications so over here you can
see that the most popular platform looks
like it's chrome
in the internet explorer and so on and
so forth
most of the traffic is coming from the
pc and
a lot of my users are also using the
smartphone mostly from from windows
also from ios and all of that
all right so the next thing i want to
show you is
the api metrics on a product level
as well as on an api proxy level right
so if i click on api proxy performance
on this dashboard you'll be able to see
what is the health
of all of my api proxies uh for the
traffic that
you've gotten what are the successes and
what are the errors
right you can see that oh my error rate
is is pretty high
actually it's eight percent so just i
need to make a mental note that i need
to
dig in to why what is causing that error
rate so we'll do that in just a second
you can also see that my average
response time for the proxy
is just a bit over 100 milliseconds for
the target
it's a bit over 250 milliseconds
these are the traffic patterns by proxy
and there's the average response time
for each of the proxies
in the same times this is for your
proxies that you are
exposing on apogee right you can also
get
um the same kind of information for your
target back-ends that
the proxies are in turn hitting to get
the right data to execute the
right logic and you can see that the
traffic by target it tells you what the
traffic patterns are um it also tells
you that
most or all of it is successful right
your backend is not throwing any errors
which is good
uh your response time um average proxy
is
about 130 average target is
close to 300 and it also tells you a bit
about the payload
you can also do latency analysis and
cache performance and all of that let me
take a look at error code analysis let's
see what kinds of errors are we throwing
so all of the errors are proxy errors we
knew that
and a majority of those errors
are 400 errors right and four xx mostly
authentication
um and bad requests and all of that
which is good
we want to deny those uh requests but a
small
percentage of it is also 500 5x errors
we should look into that what exactly is
going on there it also tells me what is
the error by proxy it looks like my
product search proxy
is receiving or generating the most
amount of errors
so we'll we'll take a look at that um
errors by target
and also proxy errors by response code
most of the response code
is 401 or 500 and some 502s
so we'll look into that as well
now let's let's dive right into
um some of the business level metrics so
i had mentioned that we have a lot of
customers that are
using these um these tools to gain
business level insights
on their revenues and on their marketing
campaigns and all of that so let me
show you how you can do it so these are
what i showed you are out of the box
reports
you have a lot of metrics and data
available so that you can create your
own custom reports
so let's say you are a big box retailer
and you have a lot of retail locations
all across the globe
for that let's say i want a revenue
report on how each one of my locations
are doing so i'll run this report
for the past hour as i just want it to
be real time
just to monitor the health and it will
tell me that hey most um
the majority or at the highest revenue
grossing store was my us-15 store
and my stores in india norway pakistan
are doing pretty well as well
as they are in the top ten right let's
say on the other hand
you are running a marketing organization
and you want to see the health of your
marketing campaigns
then let's take a look at the marketing
report let's run it for
the past hour so over here you can see
that your traffic is divided into three
different blocks and one chunk is from
social media so let's take a look
in there as you can see the report is
interactive
it tells me that i have a few different
campaigns running
one is a data privacy campaign there's
also the money back guarantee campaign
all of that
and it tells me what is a traffic
composition from each one of these
it looks like my expert compensation
campaign
is grossing the least amount of traffic
so i hope that
i'm also spending the least amount of
money on that and
the revenue per dollar spent on that
campaign
is worth my time right um so let's click
on the data privacy campaign look
look at what kinds of um
channels that the traffic is coming from
it looks like uh most of it is coming
from blogs there's also
some from google linkedin some
influencer marketing going on
in the least amount of traffic from
twitter and instagram
so it gives me a good insight into
what is working for my campaigns versus
what is not working
so now lastly what i want to show you is
api monitoring
and api monitoring is about how
is the health of your api program
in real time so what you're seeing right
now is basically a dashboard
it tells you what is the tps that your
org is
experiencing what is the error rate what
is the latency and all of that
so one feature i want to call out over
here is the alerting feature
so over here i've set a 500 error alert
to alert me whenever my proxy surpasses
and threshold
for the 500 errors and that threshold
i've said is that if there is
a constant rate of three percent of or
higher
for five minutes then please alert me
and send me an alert to this particular
email
you can choose whatever mode you want
you can integrate with anything you want
with webhook or pagerduty or slack
or email so um
if i go to my inbox
i was actually getting some 500 alerts
and i got a few alerts um just recently
so let me take a look at this
that i got about a day ago and it tells
me that
there is a playbook for me to use to
troubleshoot
that alert it also gives me the details
on exactly what the alert is
so let me let me click on view details
so it'll take me
to a report in the investigation panel
on api monitoring it tells me that hey
the status quo is 500
and here was a spike that i'm looking at
um it was constant or it was it was
pretty
stable at that threshold for about five
minutes
and that's how it got triggered is right
here
right it tells me that
the rate limit policy that i have
is triggering this so now i have a
pretty decent idea
of what exactly is going on right i
click on this it tells me that the
environment is production
this is the proxy so if you recall from
earlier
the product search proxy was also a
proxy that was um
that was throwing the most errors so i'm
not surprised by this
and looks like a lot of applications are
affected
by this particular error right so
that's good to know and also gives me
some other detail
in terms of the message processor and
also
the target that my api proxy
is is calling as part of
these api calls and
down below it tells me that
most of the errors are generated from
the proxy itself
and there are very few from the target
so 3 500 from the proxy itself so now i
know exactly where to go
right i know the particular
proxy that's that is impacted and know
the policy within the proxy that is
throwing these errors
so let me now go to develop let me click
on api
proxies and now i'll go into the product
search proxy
and i'll go into develop and
this is the policy the spiker's policy
that is throwing those errors and looks
like i'm saying that hey
if i receive more than three requests
per second then please
throw errors like don't don't let let
them pass through because i think that
is higher than i expect
i think three requests per second um
let's say i do some analysis i look at
the capacity and backend systems and
feel like you know i could probably
increase it
to seven requests per second
and save it and now it's deployed and
basically that's it now i should expect
those error rates to go down because my
spike arrest policy will get triggered
less often
so this is basically what um the apogee
analytics
and monitoring looks like
so that's it for today thank you for
joining you can find more webinars
coming out every week so please tune in
for that and you can also find
recordings of our past webinars on our
youtube channel
thanks again for joining
you